[Music]
the lessons page is where I find
interesting content to learn from the
first thing I do is make sure my level
is set correctly in the lesson feed tab
I think I'm around a beginner too so I
choose be in a 1 2 & intermediate 1 it's
always a good idea to choose the level
you think you're at the level below it
and the level above don't worry too much
about your level over time you'll find
out which lessons suit you best
it's also a good idea to change the
level of your lessons so that sometimes
you're really challenging your brain and
other times you're working more on
fluency by studying lessons that are
slightly easy for you I scroll through
the lessons in my feet these are lessons
that other link members are studying and
liking when I see an interesting lesson
I click to open it when I next return to
the lessons page I'll find this lesson
in my recent lessons at the top of the
page where I can see the four most
recent lessons I've studied at any time
I can also see all my lessons in the my
lessons tab
now let's say I'm looking for lessons
with a specific accent or on a specific
topic I want to find lessons in British
English so I go to the lesson library
tab and search British the lesson
library is huge so the best way to find
specific lessons is by searching to make
results more specific I select to show
only lessons at my level I can also sort
by likes to find the most popular
lessons as I scroll through lessons
either in the library or feed I can save
any lessons that look interesting I
don't have to open them now I can just
save them and find them later in my
lessons
take advantage of the huge lesson
library on link to learn from content
you enjoy if you enjoy it you will stay
with it and achieve your goals
happy linking